dans ce qui faisait office de salle de
réception au 16ème siècle
un ballet de lumière donné on est de
forme aux accents cosmique ou patrimoine
et art contemporain ne font qu'un passé
et présent se répondent dans cette
installation unique c'est un alignement
de planètes étoiles avec leur noyau
accompagnés par des constellations des
toiles et puis les lumières leur
permettent de créer un passage un
passage vers un multi vers un univers
parallèle qui est matérialisée par les
miroirs au sol donc on est dans une
forme de nouvelles réalités dans une
forme de rêve au milieu du cosmos
l'oeuvre est celle d'un artiste
plasticien natif de montargis et
nouvellement propriétaire des lieux avec
l'aide de sa compagne il a imaginé un
parcours immersif au coeur du château
entre rêve et réalité
l'expérience ne laisse personne de
marbre fait bizarre on en prend plein
les yeux
c'est ici qu'est delic ça nous permet de
voir autre chose de s'évader de voilà je
me sens comme ça
eric on a envie de jouer dans les brûle
c'est marrant ou tout fait tomber on est
dedans et
on est très observateur on regarde ce
qui se passe donc voilà c'est ça c'est
des moutons on va dire racheté l'été
dernier le château a nécessité onze mois
de rénovation et de remise aux normes
des ailes entières ont été réhabilités
des salles d'exposition créer tout comme
des espaces de résidence artistique
derrière ce projet de taille une seule
motivation rendre accessible le
patrimoine au plus grand nombre
mais les cette passion delà des vieilles
pierres des pierres et de digitaliser
finalement c'est pierre pour leur donner
vie et permettre une rencontre entre le
patrimoine et puis les nouvelles
générations
les propriétaires du château envisage d'
illuminé prochainement les jardins et
d'organiser des concerts
l'illumination de la tour césar et de
l'abbatiale notre dame de beaugency sont
également au programme